I'm going to drive an Uber and film it
and put the videos of conversations on
the internet I've heard that idea 8,000
times and I'm like yeah yeah yeah get in
line does let you do that they do record
some cars do record whatever's happening
right I'm pretty sure they do you just
got to tell people it's like hey like
when they get in your car and be like
hey do you mind if I film and then put
the thing on my YouTube channel and some
if someone says no be like okay and then
you don't M but Uber is a bad job anyway
I feel bad for Uber drivers you cannot
make a living doing that it destroys
your car no costs more to drive your
yeah when I get a ride from the airport
to here and it's 100 bucks I'm like what
is that like 60 40 of it goes to the
driver what crazy and that's all that's
that's going to cover gas and the wear
on the car yeah and they just spent two
and a half hours driving me like what in
the heck yeah I was reading like in New
York that uh Uber doesn't pay enough to
cover the cost of the wear and tear on
the car and gas but people don't realize
wear and tear so they're like all right
yeah made 60 bucks and it's like by the
end of the month that money you're going
to be negative cuz your car is going to
break and then you have no job